l'inquiétude au campus de jussieu
plusieurs cas de concerts viennent de se
déclarer entre liés à l'amiante placés
dans les plafonds et les placards le
comité anti amiante de jussieu réclame
une fois plus un diagnostic complet des
zones à risques et le lancement de
travaux de décontamination une enquête
jean-jacques béziers stéphane g
il suffit de lever la tête
l'amiante est apparent dans tous les
couloirs du campus de jussieu et ça fait
vingt ans que ça dure vingt ans que des
personnels sont en contact avec elle et
qu'elle les contamines aujourd'hui on
comptabilise les premiers malades
ce sont des personnes qui ont été plus
exposés que la moyenne ce qui explique
que c'est les premiers clos voit l'un
était ingénieur des travaux il a
aujourd'hui un cancer du poumon
l'autre était ingénieur d'hygiène et de
sécurité et intervenait quand il y avait
des pépins dans les labos et il a été
aussi plus exposés que la moyenne et lui
il a ce qu'on appelle une asbestose avec
des atteintes de la plèvre du diaphragme
et des poumons
donc si vous laissez les deux premiers
effectivement qui apparaissent pour
l'instant dans le personnel un comité
anti-amiante s'est constitué des
réunions s'organisent l'inquiétude
grandit parmi les soixante mille
personnes qui fréquentent
quotidiennement le campus si j'étais
vraiment cohérente avec moi même si ray
patrouille dans la mesure où ça fait 20
ans que je travaille ici en étant
exposés à l'amiante
les étudiants commencent en parler entre
eux pour spécialement enfin vraiment
maurice et les prémices comme un tout
petit peu mais avec la campagne
d'information qui lie à revenir je pense
mais plusieurs labos de recherche ont
engagé les travaux mais de manière
anarchique
il y a trois jours un faux plafond de la
tour par ici s'est effondré des
poussières d'amiante se sont échappés
laitages a été fermée le temps de
réparer mais il ya urgence il faut
trouver 200 millions et ce ne serait pas
le principal problème le problème
technique qui se pose est ce qu'on peut
le faire tout dans un temps bref sans
fermer l'université
tout le problème est là est ce que on
travaille sur un échéancier en utilisant
les périodes d'arrêt d'activité ou est
ce qu'on décide de faire mégacité
pendant un an pour le faire
et sur ce sujet tous les spécialistes ne
sont pas d'accord et quelles techniques
employées par ailleurs le dossier de
financement n'est pas bouclé après vingt
ans de débat difficile de l'admettre